first of all um
i just wanted to ask your understanding
of the latest situation in mario paul
the city is totally under siege
surrounded by enemy russian troops
without electricity water heating
without telephone reception in total
deep silence because all the buildings
and residential buildings have been
destroyed people are now sheltering in
basements and are waiting for full
evacuation
we've seen what happened in
butcher
how does that compare do you think to
what must have happened in mariopol it
was
you know when we talk about the horrors
seen by the whole civilized world today
in butcher in order to imagine what is
now happening in mariupol you have to
multiply that horror by a factor of 10
then you will understand what horror has
now taken place in mario pal so butcher
has a population of 40 000 people
mariopol has a half a million
residents
and it was mercilessly shelled by enemy
artillery and from
ships and
using grout systems and the buratina
flame thrower and by heavy
do you have an estimate on the number of
civilian casualties
before the 21st of march we managed to
record
the dead marijuana residents we were
burying them in mass graves
unfortunately by then we had
recorded the death toll of 5 000
civilians i must also stress that
shelling continued in the number of
bodies lying on the streets which we
hadn't managed to collect counted in
thousands
sky news interviewed dmitry peskov last
night
i want to ask you a little bit about
what he said
he said that mario paul is part of the
independent state of luhansk
and he wanted to assist
them
in their
being independent
and assist them from heavy suffering
that they had
from ukrainian forces
in the past over the last eight years
[Music]
yeah first of all
must
learn geography better part of lugansk
was never connected in any way with the
mariupl mariupol was part of the
nietzsche region and when in 2014 and
2015 they tried to capture the city of
mariopol then it was mariupol residents
did everything to prevent that it become
part of the so-called danish people's
republic and i think that's when this
anger was born against marijuana and all
those atrocities and destruction and
thousands of marijuana residents it
shows that it was then that mariupol
refused to bow to the so-called great
federation of russia and remained part
of an independent democratic ukraine
but
according to vladimir putin's spokesman
your city needs to be liberated
from nationalistic battalions
when putin says that we need to be
liberated from nationalists then how do
you see that they destroyed the city by
90 percent it means that in every
building in the city of marijuana all
the residents were nationalists my
mother my brother their families all the
peaceful children sheltering in the
drama theater on which they dropped two
air bombs all those people all those
pregnant women in the maternity hospital
which was also hit by an airstrike and
also the hospital where 50 wounded
people civilian people were burnt were
they all nationalists but are there
nationalists
who are terrorizing mariopol
this is just a myth this is just a
russian propaganda and the narrative
which they try to
use to brainwash their own citizens
russian citizens to justify those
atrocities which they uh commit
committed an arca meeting in ukraine you
must understand that uh russian speaking
people live in uh marijuana 98 of the
population speak russian and uh half of
the population are ethnic russians this
is all lies spread by putin himself
together with his so-called leaders of
this special operation
how has the feeling of the people of
mariopol changed
in the last
few weeks in the last since this
invasion started how is how is that
sentiment towards russia changed
yeah i want to reassure you firmly that
the attitude has changed radically we
understand now very clearly what kind of
voice is and when vladimir putin said in
the autumn that there is no such nation
as ukrainians i want to assure you that
he has done everything with this war
that this nation we you as ukrainians no
matter what our ethnic origin is all the
residents of ukraine jews polls ethnic
ukrainians or russians armenians as
aries they have all become one nation
one ukrainian nation i just wanted to
get your reaction to
um
what's happened today at kramatosk
there's been two missiles hitting
the station
it looks like civilians have been killed
at least 30.
yes more than 30 civilians died today as
a result of these atrocities and strikes
committed by the russian federation
against the peaceful kramatorsk at the
time when people
were trying to evacuate
civilians children elderly women waiting
for a train to go to a safer area of
ukraine the cynicism which were
witnessed in mariupol when they
were shelling the drummers theater or
the maternity hospital so those uh
russian telegram channels and the social
media when they said that they should
take evacuation trains so they knew in
advance that they would commit this
crime and which they have committed
today it looks as if russia is
has
you know it is withdrawn from areas
around kiev and that it may well focus
now on the east
and the south of ukraine
what do you think is going to happen
and what do you think
the west should do about it
we understand that the main water day
now will be fought for donetsk and
lagasse regions that all the forces will
be concentrated there and the result of
all this will be decided on the
battlefield and we have to prepare now
for what is happening today those cities
that are being hit by those missile
strikes there will be airstrikes as well
those cities and towns have to prepare
to evacuate their civilians and to
prepare the two women children and the
elderly should leave those towns which
are now facing that threat
what what more should um countries like
the united kingdom the european union
and the americans
do we must understand that only economic
sanctions can stop now that army and
that leader who issued that criminal
order and only
economic and financial sanctions and
attack against his economy will work we
need a full embargo on the purchase of
russian oil and gas we understand that
only in the first quarter of this year
the russian federation has already
earned 35 billion
which it spends on the war with ukraine
by the end of the year they will earn
another 300 billion and if we don't
impose an embargo it's clear that the
russian federation will continue the war
and those who buy
those commodities they must understand
that their
co-finances of this war which is
destroying and raising to the ground
such cities as marijuana and butcher
finally
come bring back to our interview with
dmitry peskov yesterday
he said that
the images we've seen of
civilians who look like they've been
shot
are fake
he said that the hospital as we've heard
before
images we saw from maripo
were faked
um
how can you prove that they're not faked
there are many witnesses now the
witnesses of the tragic events in
mariopol in the drama theater my mom is
one of those witnesses she spent 20 days
there sheltering hiding against russian
strikes there are many witnesses who are
ready and are already giving evidence
against those
atrocities committed by the russian
federation and putin